first time you ever science signed on
without seeing script yes for a moment I
panicked and then I was like okay well
yeah because the character was very
boring when I read it right but you're
scripting me yeah she was very she was
the straight person in the movie oh yeah
and she was like the typical male boss
but in a woman and he was bland and I'd
like it serve a purpose but it was no
no's it was not spirited or fun or funny
and Miguel was like yeah that's why I'm
spice it up with a golf club
how much fun was this with the golf club
Golf Club it's actually Miguel's idea
that was one of the things that was not
my idea and it was like a way of having
like a phallic figure to feel the power
this was the thing we must start instead
of like we might start something with
the golf right you don't say no this
movie is all about female empowerment
you've been so involved in Hollywood
over the past couple years with this
whole movement is there someone in
Hollywood right now that you're looking
to that's really making some boss moves
like a female out there that you think
like wow they're really killing it right
now is there any one that comes to mind
Tiffany yeah and by the way Rose who
plays I should not I know you didn't
want to hear it sounds like oh well she
did the typical answer yeah yeah but let
me tell you a different you know what I
had a boss once oh that oh my god the
jet like is hitting both once that was
really amazing yeah Tina Fey oh really
well yeah that's a good one
Tina Fey is incredible she hired me for
30 rock and I was going to do like one
or two episodes I ended up I think doing
seven and she
a great boss I saw you post a couple
days ago to like another one would be
Angelina Jolie your oh my god I love
your post you said like you weren't
expecting to make such great friends on
that movie like what was it I love you
guys done no we're still shooting I love
her I sincerely think C she's so much
more special than everything you see
right and she's such a good mom right
congratulations I'm so low by the way
everybody this movie yeah it's great but
I've really connected with this amazing
girl I thought she was gonna be like
colder or distant or I did have things
that I didn't you know you don't know
she's an icon you don't know what it's
gonna be
you do know she's gonna be a great
actress but I'm very surprised she's
warm and lovely
we can't resist this charm so thank you
very much the view